ces affrontements ont fait monter d'un
cran la tension entre les différents
acteurs présents militairement dans la
région recep tayyip erdogan adressé un
ultimatum à la syrie lui demandant
d'éloigner ses troupes des postes
d'observation militaire turc d'ici la
fin février le gouvernement syrien reçu
un sérieux châtiment surtout à est libre
mais cela ne suffit pas il y aura une
suite car plus ils attaqueront nos
militaires
plus ils paieront cher très cher les
tensions entre ankara et damas ne semble
parti pour s'apaiser
une situation qui préoccupe le
secrétaire général de l'otan james
stoltenberg qui a exhorté les deux camps
à cesser les hostilités
je suis très préoccupé par la situation
à m libre car nous avons été témoin d'
attaques horribles contre les civils
[Musique]
nous avons vu à nouveau que des
centaines de milliers de personnes ont
été forcées à fuir et nous avons
également vu des bombardements aveugles
de cibles civiles et nous condamnons
cela parce que nous condamnons également
les attaques aveugles contre des cibles
civiles s'imposant comme médiateur
incontournable du conflit syrien
la russie se dit elle aussi inquiète de
la situation et réclament l'arrêt de
toute activité terroriste dirigé contre
les installations militaires russes nous
pensons que maintenant le plus important
c'est le respect des accords de sotchi
c'était important et ça le reste est
aussi éliminé l'activité terroriste
dirigé contre les forces armées
syriennes et les infrastructures
militaires russes nous considérons que
de telles offensives depuis il dribble
sont inacceptables
selon l'onu près de sept cent mille
personnes ont été déplacées dans le
nord-ouest du pays depuis début décembre
la turquie redoute que l'offensive de
damas ne provoque une nouvelle
migratoire vers la turquie où plus de
trois millions et demi de syriens ont
trouvé refuge depuis 2011
[Musique]